Eugene I wear my vest just for you it's
a beautiful best we're here to tell you
about Startalk lives
yeah if I'd be rate 27 for every or 27
Hall 43rd Street West 43rd Street us
there - you what minded start talk live
wait we previously did a bunch of those
in Brooklyn
yeah we're bringing it to men and
bringing it to Manhattan and Startalk
Takes Manhattan
with special guests and the topic is
going to be like the moon Mars and
Beyond yeah and oh yeah I'm gonna take
you there and drop you there I can't
wait to go to the moon Mars and Beyond
was a very special guests yeah we can't
tell you who we know who the guests are
we're not what like faking this we know
who the guests are we're just not
tending you okay February 27th 8:00 p.m.
town hall be there thank you